Ric Flair stormed off the set of kill
Tony last week claiming he was
uncomfortable with the format and
refused to take part in a show that
demeans people these are the top three
awkward moments from Ric Flair on kill
Tony starting off with number three no
don't I love you I am don't leave no
humor in the world that makes fun of
people
kill Tony might be the last place on
Earth to say there's no humor in the
world that makes fun of people but it's
still less awkward than moment number
two when nobody could tell if Rick was
even still awake
fall asleep no he's on his phone it's
like fun Joe Biden the fact that he's
not
he's not even him is rough but it's
definitely not rougher than when the
Nature Boy finally had enough of this
show and decided to hit the road we lost
Ric Flair everybody I can have fun I
will never make fun of time of people
donate their personal time to making
children better a very drunk